quite a different scene here today there
are no cars being stopped and searched
like we saw last night but take a look
behind me this facility has Barbed wires
all around it but still somehow this
inmate was able to get out
posters of periphyo Duarte a Herrera
plastered in front of local businesses
surrounding Southern desert Correctional
Center on it says he escaped September
27th but Nevada Department of
Corrections confirmed he escaped from
prison Friday night most likely that
dude's in another state or country by
now Paul lundquitz is a president of the
Fraternal Order of Police a union
representing correctional officers in
Nevada we asked him how an inmate could
plan an escape without being noticed for
days the inmate was able to defeat his
cell window with either the combination
of battery acid or manipulating the the
frame to where he could open the window
and you know get out of there I'm
assuming he had worked at that for some
time but as to why it took so long for
someone to notice Herrera was gone
lunkowitz confirms our report from
yesterday that he placed a dummy made
out of cardboard on his bed but with it
being so short stuffed he says something
like this was bound to happen something
like this doesn't happen you know to the
level that it did with just one
breakdown it doesn't happen by just one
single breakdown it's not one person's
fault this is this is a multi-level
thing that factors contribute to allow
for something like this to happen we
have also learned at the time of the
inmates escape the tower closest to the
prison fence was not manned he says head
counts are done up to seven times a day
with correction officers looking inside
the prison cell to count for inmates as
for the chances of capturing Herrera
Longwood says if he's really doesn't
want to be found and he's really like
getting out of the country to
non-extradition place or something like
that I you know it'll take pure luck at
this point because if you're that many
days behind somebody
and today we also learned Metro Police
is helping the U.S Marshals in searching
for this inmate although it's unclear
how far they're stretching their search